the war in Ukraine set to dominate talks
when NATO foreign ministers meet in
Romania in the coming hours the alliance
needs to decide exactly how it will help
defend it against Russian air and ground
attacks we'll check in with Rory
challenge in Kiev in a minute
Andrew Simmons is standing by for us in
Bucharest but first is his report on how
the alliance is making its presence felt
near Ukraine's borders
Romania is building its defenses at a
fast rate here a transformation of its
main air base is underway
usf-16 aircraft have replaced outdated
former Soviet migs only 17 f-16s for now
but 32 more on the way everything is
under pressure so we were time limited
all the time we fight against the second
we have a lot of mission Runnings and
this is all the missions are focused on
giving us more Security in the safe
environment I would say we are defining
the Romanian airspace and overall we are
contributing to the NATO security
and it is a big
it's an important time but we are doing
what we are prepared to do every day
by every day he means the coordination
with other NATO forces policing the
airspace and 24-hour standby for any
incidents
into the skies above NATO's Eastern
flank has never been so intense NATO
faces a colossal challenge not just in
the air
but on the ground too
Russia would call this escalation NATO
prefers the word deterrence here U.S and
Romanian forces on an exercise recently
these Maneuvers came only a week after a
stray Ukrainian air defense missile
crossed the border exploding in Poland
killing two people
Germany has offered Patriot missile
systems to defend polish airspace Poland
wants the systems to be positioned on
the Ukrainian side of the Border while
Germany doesn't appear to agree however
increased Russian attacks on Ukraine's
energy infrastructure mean there's a
clamoring among some NATO states to give
Ukraine more air defenses with major
power outages at a time when Sub-Zero
temperatures are worsening a
humanitarian emergency is becoming more
severe by the day President Putin is now
trying to use a weapon I use the winter
as a weapon or war against Ukraine uh
and this is horrific the NATO foreign
Minister's meeting is undoubtedly going
to hear that additional Advanced Air
Defense systems are urgently needed for
Ukraine along with more training in
their use
Landry Simmons is live for us in
Bucharest so Andrew what are the NATO
foreign ministers going to come up with
to comfort countries uh like the one
you're in
well certainly that is one issue in
terms of priorities for nato in terms of
putting uh he couldn't say it ease
because they certainly don't feel at
ease but to try to placate concerns in
Border countries such as Romania and
indeed Poland that their defense is
going to be adequate the Secretary
General of NATO has been saying
categorically that
assistance has never been higher than
foreign troops from NATO allies are all
over now the Border areas and equipment
is arriving every day to reinforce that
a whole approach but the key issue with
this NATO foreign Minister's meeting is
how Ukraine can be helped with this new
crisis it's facing on top of every other
one and that is these Russian attacks on
the energy infrastructure of the country
which is having such a massive effect
making families get stuck in a situation
without any power without any heating a
blackouts all over the country when
these attacks take place so there are
it's a strong argument that the air
defenses have to be improved and for
that to happen and NATO allies need to
actually breach some of their internal
rulings that they about putting Weaponry
into the uh into the country uh putting
a surface-to-air missile systems which
are defensive systems but of course they
are missiles so there is a controversy
among some states about putting that
Weaponry in so that's going to be an
area of discussion furthermore what
practical Aid can be given to try and
combat these blackouts uh we're good to
hear it was seen where according to
sources Secretary of State the US
Secretary of State Anthony blinken
outline a plan the U.S has to put
millions of dollars if not billions into
trying to get repairs made at to
Transformers and other substations
within Ukraine to try and get that power
back that is the humanitarian issue
really it's not something perhaps NATO
directly is concerned with there perhaps
more inclined to go for the issue of the
air defenses but the U.S might have many
other things up its sleeves in terms of
what sort of military aid and what sort
of sort of further Aid it can give
towards trying to make the lives of
ukrainians slightly easier over the
winter because they're facing a massive
challenge a real really miserable
position with sub-zero temperatures all
right thanks so much to Andrew Simmons
let's keep this going though we've got
Rory challenge he's live for us in the
Ukrainian Capital now in Kiev so Rory
Andrew there talking about what NATO can
do to help Ukraine with its challenge
how does the battlefield situation look
for that challenge facing Ukraine
I would say there's a very particular
feeling in Ukraine at the moment uh I
wouldn't call it fear I call it
anticipation if you've ever taken a
punch you kind of know this sensation
it's when you've taken a breath in and
you're tensed and you're waiting uh for
that blow to land because ukrainians
know it's coming zelenski in his Sunday
address said that there was going to be
another huge wave of Russian airstrikes
on the country's energy infrastructure
yesterday there was all sorts of talk on
social media about Russian warships with
cruise missiles heading out into the
Black Sea Russian strategic bombers
being loaded up with cruise missiles
ready for the takeoff but so far we
haven't had the air raid sirens and the
strikes haven't arrived but I think the
feeling is that you know they are coming
and people just need to make sure that
they're as ready as they can possibly be
so people are going out and they're
making sure they've got enough candles
they've made sure they've got enough
water in their plastic bottles stacked
up in the bathroom they're making sure
that their power banks are charged and
if they've got generators that those are
full of diesel and then there's the
psychological aspect we've got to
basically put your Brave face on you've
got a smile you've got to make sure that
you're telling yourself and other people
that this is being done for the right
reasons you can endure it it's for
freedom and it's for Independence that's
the kind of psychological basis that
people are living under here on an on a
strategic uh National level well of
course we've just heard from Andrew
about what Ukraine wants from its
Western allies it's very simple air
defense to be able to shoot the Russian
missiles down when they come in and
therefore and and but if any missiles do
get through which they probably will
then there has to be financial
assistance to rebuild to get the power
back up Transformers Etc it's a pretty
simple shopping list but it's a crucial
one all right thanks so much Rory
challenge